présentée était une star moi je sais
quoi là les enfants là et c'était comme
des oufs ils sont cette fois les années
1960 la fmh dénonce venir on a eu plein
de gens hitman est totale je te jure
c'est un truc de fou
j'ai vu que tu étais tu as eu un petit
moment de t2 tu voulais prendre un petit
et dix pâtés distance mais clairement ça
c'est ça doit être ça doit être au loup
un peu dans le genre quoi bah comment
déjà j'ai été une super tôt dans cette
voie cette vie d'artiste ça veut dire
des voeux je supportais j'ai appris j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses plus avec les
réseaux et tous pourris bois et sur les
réseaux et moi ça veut dire qu'en 3d les
réseaux c'est les réseaux des fois les
gens sont méchants moi j'étais en gros
j'avais 15 ans je me dis ouais c'est pas
si ça doit pas et si c est quoi ca et un
an après j'ai pu cette mentalité je me
dis c'est vraiment un genre faut être
fort mentalement pour être dans ce monde
c'est vrai on a eu des moments où tu as
eu déjà eu des coups de blues comme tout
le monde
enfin c'est normal mais ça a été des
gros coup de mou score à un moment tu
t'es dit j'en ai marre je vais arrêter
j'ai envie de reprendre une vie dans
leur foi bah oui plusieurs fois des fois
je pose des questions bajard comme j'ai
pu le lire dans plusieurs de mes
interviews sur mon avenir esprit es que
ça ça ira pas une grosse ampleur sur mon
avenir c'est un jour j'ai des enfants je
sais pas d'être comme ça en gros je
pense vraiment à moi plus tard
est-ce que ça va le faire en jeu ça mais
c'est vrai que je me sens beaucoup plus
angoissés que quand je t'avais vu la
draft est heureuse bien entendu mais
c'est vrai que tu te poses tu poses des
questions voilà tu te dis c'est vrai que
là c'est presque normal je pense que
tout s'était passé par là donc c'est
normal en cravate en boitant vie toi toi
tu as envie de durer combien tu as envie
d'or il est là pendant quoi maintenant
les gens veulent peut-être à
l'international et de remplir un stade
de france après chose que j'aurais fait
ma mission ah ouais bah écoute ok bah
bracci croit un stade de france qui
croit franchement j'y croyais les
anciens en revanche s'ils ne n'y va pas
avec quoi tu vas le vide et très vite ah
oui alors c'est une question vous avez
explosé en 2020 en parlant de deux
stades de france donc en plein qu'ovide
vous n'avez pas pu vraiment faire de
concert ni de bouchot khezzar vous avez
un public énorme c'est frustrant pour
vous ouaddou fait genre j'ai explosé
j'étais le phénomène du moins en moins
et tout mais j'ai jamais rencontrées par
si je rentre sans rue mais j'ai pas fait
de scène j'ai trois chacun le cas de
choquer ce depuis que bah je suis connue
mais ça m'énerve parce que
j'aimerais pas perdre et ce n est tout
j'ai un zénith en décembre et j'espère
qu'il va pas être annulée parce
qu'au-delà ma tournée on l'annulé ça
m'énerve des frères du oui j'ai une
entière une petite soeur ou un petit
frère
et comment ils réagissent raïs qui
disent je suis le frère de will then
suis la soeur de m
tout le monde le sait parce que sur un
staff 1 on sait que c'est leur
instrument et ça c'est ils sont heureux
ils sont ils sont faits ils sont heureux
bas ils ont beaucoup plus d'avant
beaucoup plus davantage maintenant voilà
oui c'est un méchant dans la rue quoi ah
ouais ouais mais sinon franchement ça va
aller des parents ma mère c'est trop
maman poule mais n'empêche pas connu ça
a toujours été mars que bon et sa mère
en fait elle a 30 ans et que sa mère
c'est guillaume genton elle est superbe
wertret enfin l'espère ouverte trop
contente que partant quartier je suis
contente avec soutien c'est un quota